[Música]
reunimos a 6 videojugadores soy
videojuego soy un videojuego soy un
videojuego todo yo un videojugador vídeo
jugadas hoy vídeo jugador uno de ellos
miente si el grupo descubre quién está
mintiendo se repartirán el premio en
efectivo
si el que miente sobrevive él o ella se
ganará todo el premio
[Música]
me pregunto si el jugador de verdad como
se llama esta pose o docente como bien
confío en el cuál es tu usuario de
facebook lo grita alguien más tienes tim
phillips y con estuco de clock y una
tina absolute unit con una foto de
booking de diddy noble y 357 y el mío se
especifica en chica en chivo con una
foto de leeloo xivert aunque juega
mayormente en la pc yo juego over watch
yo juego ni hip hop y si está bien o el
lic
a mí me gusta mucho los juegos de
simulación juego mucho los sims un juego
varios juego lic pero también juego de
este pokemon hasta darkest dongen de
todo en realidad
excepto horror me gustan las cosas de
horror de los 90 ahora estoy jugando
hunting ustedes conocen hunting es como
un juego de horror
[Risas]
bien esta es la primera ronda pero
tenemos un empate entre jessica y press
bien así que tenemos otro empate
jajajaja
cada uno de los empatados tendrá 30
segundos para dar su testimonio sobre sí
mismos
no soy muy mala en eso está bien
combate piedra papel o tijera miel
piedra papel o tijera piel
bien alguno de ustedes ha jugado es
lenderman por supuesto que está bien
saben que hay diez lugares cierto se
está la camioneta azul la camioneta roja
y todos los caminos en el bosque sabe
además si sé bien lo mío yo soy el
impulsor aquí mis conocimientos sobre
videojuegos no son muy buenos cuando
estoy bajo presión conozco el leeds os
legend y conozco bien lo que hago cual
rol juega allí cuál es tu campeón
preferido juego ética risas normalmente
también me gusta allí no está bien suelo
jugar con esas
o con juegos de granjas y de joven
también en qué rango estás tú todos
queremos saber ahora 27 si la temporada
se lava de récord juego el tiempo ha
terminado
[Risas]
ha sido asesinada buena suerte y gracias
a dios bien volvamos a la pregunta
inicial sobre cuál es el videojuego
favorito de cada uno qué tal si contamos
la primera vez que lo jugamos para mí
tiene un hard es mi favorito es una gran
parte de mi vida me encanta ese juego
sora y riku son mis personajes favoritos
saben de hecho tengo el collar de kindle
harold conmigo como estadísticas y la
razón por la que entré en league fue
porque mis amigos de otro juego se
cambiaron todos a league y desde
entonces comencé a jugarlo con mi novia
y mis primos mi juego favorito es
pokemon general he jugado en mi rol
desde que era un niño recuerdo que me
tomo 7 años para vencer var el dom
recuerdo que estaba tan emocionado que
saque la cámara de inmediato y comencé a
tomarle fotos y publicarlo en todas
partes un gran momento para mi bien
para mí mi juego favorito tal vez es
paper mario la primera vez que vi el
juego mi hermano lo jugaba y me me
encantó mi juego favorito es until done
el cual empezamos a jugar en la
universidad mi amiga vi lo jugaba en la
sala y desde entonces tal vez tanto que
saben
ya no puedo contar bien crucemos datos
del tiempo cruzados si en tu primera vez
quien murió que murió como la primera
persona que murió o que muchas personas
murieron
quien sobrevivió en mi primera vez fue
la pareja la chica mala quien es
verónica
y después si no hay una verónica en el
juego no no
no
soy ella señalando diciendo que soy un
impuesto
a
la silla caliente cuál es el nombre del
monstruo en el juego bueno puedo decirte
que es como un murciélago no es un
murciélago
no hay murciélagos bueno son vampiros no
estoy diciendo que se vaya pero tampoco
no tiene acorralado
un monstruo es como no puedes decir que
hay múltiples son ciegos pero tú
y yo traté de como oigan continuemos
pero había como una pared se llaman wind
y cause por cierto windows y son windows
veronica hay una verónica josh o flores
que te lo juro hay una pero nica lo juro
no hay una pero única
honestamente mi mente se quedó en blanco
cuando me pregunto por los personajes no
se me venía a la mente ningún nombre lo
único que se me ocurrió fue los actores
y actrices y por eso dije verónica había
una pequeña parte de mí que pensaba
sabes qué
debe ser difícil estar en el centro de
escrivá veronica es delgada tiene
cabello negro corto hasta aquí tiene un
pequeño lunar aquí ojos marrones ella es
como la mala de ahí ella es como la
ciencia si eso es así lee
y no es veronica no entiendo por qué me
estás tratando de llevar la contraria
mike dios
es
un hombre
que tiene doble trenzas no sé por qué yo
estoy en la silla caliente cuando tú
eres la que claramente está diciendo los
nombres equivocados porque no tengo
tiempo
necesitamos que otras personas
particiones recuerde
leyendo
algunas únicas dos no jugué sonic
adventure 2 es un juego me encanta el
ejército
no siempre parece
[Música]
saben que buscar su nombre es veronica
no hay una verónica en el juego levanten
la mano si están seguros de que el
impostor se fue y quieren dejar el juego
hasta aquí es muy pronto
una ronda más creo
de acuerdo el juego continúa
si bien cual rol usualmente juegas y
cuál estoy muy bien favorito
vícar bélicos y mal sahar bien entonces
eres mí si yo te entiendo a jugar a
blogs ahora acá zona
y ni a ni soporte o mid ambos bien qué
tal pregunta cuál es el último juego que
se compraron en el último que se
compraron
cuál fue el último juego que compre dame
un chance con eso porque no he comprado
un juego desde hace un tiempo tengo
convert bondel así que yo recibo muchos
juegos cada mes no recuerdas el último
que recibiste de home volvo
el último juego que recibí de yumbel
bond el slide spyer lo cual fue hace
como dos meses no he revisado este mes
todavía pero si es ley de españa
recibiese bien
se está acabando el tiempo es todo
[Música]
ha sido asesinada
levanten las manos y creen que ya
sacaron al impostor
de acuerdo bien
si la luz cambia a verde sacaron al
impostor si la luz cambia a rojo el
impostor sigue en la caca y perderán
haremos una pequeña formación como si
de italia no te quede muy de frente
bien
y
el impostor puede dar un paso al frente
para rebelarse
verónicas y
ese es un momento épico de jugador jugué
sobre no hacer tu postura sobre los
videojuegos no juegas para nada o sólo
un poco tengo un game cue pero
probablemente juego una vez al año es la
verdad
[Música]
docente para el final
jubilee vive intensamente